[موسيقى]
قبل كان الماء عالي وصيد موجود الحمد لله
والشكر اقل واحد ما يقارب يصير الا بال
200 250 الف دينار بالعراقي هسه حاليا ما
يصير لك حتى 6000 دينار 7000 ما يجيب لك
وقت ما يجيب لك الاطفال لك هسه صاير تعبان
250 دينار
[موسيقى]
كنا نصير نعمه خير
اليوم
25 الى 30 طن
هسه حاليا
ماكو وين الماء
ماكو ماكو شغل
على
مستوى العراق
انتهت
مالها تذكر وهذا الحلال
[موسيقى]
بهذا المكان
ايه والله هات اشوف وانا صار الصحابه
كانت العالم كلها مستفاده والعده مستفاد
العده يصير سمك كلها مستفاده
بعد والناس
في الوقت نفسه هنالك السوء لاداره الموارد
المائيه في العراق سوء كبير اهدرنا كثير
من المياه عبر انظمه الري الموائم للزراعه
والغير مجديه اللي هي انظمه الرئيس
السومريه قنوات مفتوحه
بحيث صرفنا من عام 20 21 الى 20 22 اكثر
من 21 مليار متر مكعب من السجود الرئيسيه
والخزنات سدوا كان سد الموصل سد حديثه
وكذلك بحيره الثالثه للاسف الشديد كان
علينا ان ننتقل من اداره الفيضان الى
اداره الجفاف وهنا لك ثلاث سيناريوهات
لاداره الجفاف لكننا همم
لم ياخذ هذا الموضوع بنظره الاحتبار ومنذ
عام 20 20 حيث وفره المياه الى اليوم كان
هناك كبير بالمياه وانا اعتقد ان انا
فقدنا اكثر من 200 مليار متر مكعب خلال
هذه السنوات الاربعه
لم يعد من السهل اعاده الامور الى ما كانت
عليه سابقا بنسبه المساحه الخضراء
والمراعي تقلصت بشكل مخيف لاسباب كثيره
ونتيجه الظروف الصعبه التي يعيشها البلد
منذ سنوات طويله انهار جفت واخرى في طريق
الجفاف لا يامل العراقيون من تربتها
الكثيره ما يضعوا في حساباتهم انه لا حلول
في المستقبل القريب فاهوارهم تجف امام
اعينهم اسوه ببقيتي مقدرات البلاد